I think they should be angry at Alvin
Bragg because there may be a decent case
against Trump at least more decent than
this one in the special prosecutor Jack
Smith who's looking into whether he
openly defied a subpoena that was served
upon him and Mar-A-Lago and had his
lawyer say he turned over everything
when he hadn't that one is at least
interesting it is colorable this one's a
joke it makes a joke out of the justice
system it's absurd to violate nearly 250
years of precedent and not going after
uh former presidents criminally with
this are you kidding me it's an
embarrassment and it's obviously an
attempt to fulfill a campaign Promise by
Alvin Bragg who not wants not twice but
repeatedly over a dozen times touted his
record of getting Trump of having been
part of at least 100 lawsuits against
the Trump organization and the Trump
family and Donald Trump himself
promising he was just the man to do it
if they would put him in office